hey guys I'm just McDonald it's the
tenth of June today and you're tuned in
for another episode of GameSpot news
today is the second day of e3 although
technically they call it day one I guess
the logic is strong with this Expo
anyway let's get into the highlights
from sony and ubisoft's conferences
yesterday as well as the Nintendo one
from this morning Ubisoft's conference
was pretty much rounded up into them
telling us all about their already
announced games fortunately when you're
announced games of that good nobody
really seems to mind the publisher
kicked it off with our first real look
at far cry 4 which featured the main
antagonist being a real piece of crap
and then taking a selfie with the
protagonist what followed was a couple
of really solid looks at the crew and
Assassin's Creed unity which we've seen
previously but never looked quite as
good as they did in the UV presser the
lovely French Revolution setting for the
brutal AC unity was shown off and as for
the racing title the crew a super cool
sped up trailer made the game look way
better than it did during last year's
debut UV rounded it up with some
multiplayer fun times in the division
which was supplemented by an intriguing
story trailer and they then revealed
Rainbow six siege for new gen and PC the
reboot of rainbow 6 patriots is a 5v5
squad based shooter which is set to keep
you came through his upcoming shootie
offerings a bunch of awesome things
happened at sony's press conference and
whether you missed it or not it's
totally worth reiterating that GTA 5 is
coming to PC also ps4 and Xbox one
obviously the whole GTA 5 coming to ps4
part was what Sony focused on but
Rockstar have said that regardless of
the platform the game will have
across-the-board graphical and technical
improvements and a stunning new level of
details specifically the developer has
said you can look forward to increased
draw distances finer textured details
denser traffic and enhanced resolutions
also new wildlife finally sony also hit
the announcements hard telling us that
uncharted 4 a thief and we'll be landing
on piers
or in 2015 Drake looked lovely and super
detailed although mildly injured but
even though the action game closed alpha
show it wasn't the only surprise
nostalgic adventure game fans everywhere
suffered minor head inclusions after it
was revealed that Tim Schafer's Grim
Fandango would be coming to ps4 and Vita
the last thing worth mentioning is that
we got a serious lab of far cry 4
gameplay we got to see the two-player
cooperative mode in action as well as
super dangerous stampeding elephants and
brand new lease will take down and the
last thing we need to talk about is the
super fun and adorable madness that was
the Nintendo digital event this morning
Bayonetta 2 made an appearance as did
the gorgeously adorable Yoshi's woolly
world but the biggest hit of the day was
certainly the brand new Legend of Zelda
for Wii U we were treated to an insanely
cool looking trailer and told that
they're completely prep to make an
open-world 3d Hyrule happen again
basically just enjoy watching it and
then watching it over and over and over
again until we get our next glimpse of
this epic title appearing in 2015
Nintendo also revealed the lovely Mario
maker where players can utilize the Wii
U gamepad to create levels from scratch
if you know the creative type is still
worth gathering a little height for the
starfox game that's coming to Wii U
according to Time magazine the game is
still fundamentally a spaceship based
shooter and if you pick it up you'll be
using the gamepad motion controls to aim
and fire and Arwen's weapons you'll also
be able to turn that sweet our wing into
a land tank if it takes your fancy let
me know what conference was your
favorite of this year's selection and
which game is Chuck your fancy if you're
interested in all the e3 bits and pieces
coming out of this year's Expo be sure
to stay tuned to gamespot com /e three
and we'll be back tomorrow